en la serie de vídeos pasada que era de
números imaginarios que espero que hayas
visto pero si no no te preocupes vimos
que a veces teníamos que sacar la raíz
de un número negativo por ejemplo a
veces nos tenemos que enfrentar a sacar
la raíz de menos 1 o no sé por ejemplo
la raíz de menos 9 por decir algo como
en los números reales cualquier número
al cuadrado da 0 o bien algo positivo
entonces no podíamos encontrar un número
real que fuera la raíz de menos 1 ni la
de menos 9 para resolver esta dificultad
entonces nos pasábamos a otro tipo de
números y para esto lo primerito que
hacíamos era definir a la unidad
imaginaria y ahí vale y lo que cumplía y
por definición es que era un número tal
que al elevarlo al cuadrado nos diera
igual a menos 1 y gracias a este número
y podíamos pues ahora sí simplificar
expresiones de este estilo de la
siguiente forma podríamos poner que raíz
de menos 9 es igual a y por raíz de 9 y
como 9 ya es un número positivo esto nos
queda igual a 3
entonces podemos decir que la raíz de
menos 9 es igual a 3 y para justificar
un poquito más pues vamos a elevar 3 y
al cuadrado 3 y al cuadrado la idea es
que nos dé menos 9 vamos a ver si a ver
aquí usando propiedades de los
exponentes me queda 3 al cuadrado x
al cuadrado y esto que nos queda pues
saber 3 al cuadrado es 9 le voy a poner
aquí igual a 9 y al cuadrado es igual a
menos 1 entonces le voy a poner aquí el
menos por lo tanto 3 y al cuadrado si
nos da menos 9 y esto justifica que
extendamos nuestro nuestra definición de
este simbolito de raíz para decir que
raíz de menos 9 es igual a 3 y vale a
los números de esta forma de la forma
real por la unidad imaginaria le
llamábamos números imaginarios y bueno
para decir un poquito acerca de eso pues
no es que sean números así que no
existan o que no sean tan concretos como
los otros números los números
imaginarios son bien concretos y existen
como los otros números
por ejemplo los números negativos pues
podemos debatir si existen o no pero si
son números que utilizamos
qué hacemos operaciones y que son de
mucha utilidad en el mismo sentido los
números imaginarios también hacen eso y
por lo tanto el nombre imaginario es un
poco injusto pero bueno no me quiero
meter mucho con eso este a más bien de
lo que te quiero platicar ahorita es de
un tipo de números que mezclan los
números reales con los números
imaginarios y esos aparecen cuando
resolvemos ecuaciones cuadráticas déjame
bajar para para que veamos a qué me
refiero
entonces me refiero a que a veces puedes
encontrarte números digamos de la forma
55 más 2 y así más 2
a estos números les llamamos números
complejos son números que tienen una
parte real y una parte imaginaria y esto
no se puede simplificar podemos pensar
que viven en diferentes dimensiones el 5
y el 2 y vale entonces estoy aquí es un
número complejo y bueno para explicar un
poquito más eso de las diferentes
dimensiones déjame pitar por acá un eje
un eje vertical vamos a pensar que estoy
acá es el eje de los complejos y acá un
eje horizontal
vamos a pensar perdón este es el eje
imaginario este es el eje de los números
reales entonces vamos a aquí le voy a
poner imaginario de aquí real y lo que
vamos a hacer es visualizar este número
cinco más dos y aquí en este plano vale
y como le vamos a hacer pues vamos a
poner un punto en algún lugar pensando
en que 5 y 2 son las coordenadas como 5
es la parte real tenemos que avanzar
cinco unidades aquí
aquí queda el 5 y luego 2 unidades hacia
arriba entonces este numerito lo podemos
pasar aquí para visualizarlo entonces
este es el 5 + 2
muy bien bueno ya tenemos números
complejos ya tenemos una forma de
visualizarlos después hablaremos un poco
de las aplicaciones pero ahorita déjame
decirte cómo podemos hacer sumas y
restas vaya operaciones con ellos para
esto vamos a tomar dos complejos
entonces pensemos que tenemos dos
números complejos vamos a llamarles no
sé a más y vamos a poner otro que es de
más de y si queremos como queremos ver
cómo sumarlos prestarlos multiplicarlos
y dividirlos ahora una pequeña nota en
los números reales cuando tenemos así un
número arbitrario le llamamos x si pero
podemos haberle llamado a j lo que sea
pero x es algo más o menos estándar
cuando estamos en el contexto de los
números complejos
vamos a utilizar la variable zeta sale
otra vez podemos utilizar otras
variables pero usar z como que ayuda a
hacernos a la idea de que son números
complejos entonces a este primer número
déjame llamarle
vale y a este segundo vamos a llamarle z
2 entonces lo que quiero ver es quién es
z 1 + z 2 set a uno más z 2 bueno pues
vamos a intentar encontrar la definición
pues sumando estas dos cosas entonces si
sumamos z1 con z 2 nos quedaría z 1 es a
más b y es más puedo ponerlo así entre
paréntesis este de aquí es z 1 y luego
vamos a sumar los estados que es c +
cómo le hacemos para hacer esta suma
pues no podemos juntar partes reales con
partes imaginarias entonces tenemos que
juntar partes reales con partes reales
estos de aquí nos quedaría igual a ambas
se lo voy a poner así entre paréntesis a
más y luego vamos a ver que nos queda en
la parte imaginaria si tenemos bbc si a
eso le sumamos de veces y entonces en
total juntamos b más de b más de x y
vale entonces está muy fácil hacer la
suma de números complejos la parte real
que queda es la suma de las partes
reales y la parte imaginaria es la suma
de las partes imaginarias vale
ok para hacer la resta es algo muy
similar déjame cambiar el color para que
no quede tan monótono para hacer la
resta si queremos hacer zeta 1 - zeta 2
pues es exactamente la misma idea que en
la suma sólo que ahora restamos las
partes reales y restamos las partes
imaginarias entonces
nos quedaría a menos c si restamos las
partes reales más
de b/d por y por y observa que lo estoy
escribiendo de esta forma como real
comparte imaginaria para que veamos que
de veras quedan números complejos esta
es la idea queremos ver que la suma de
complejos es compleja y ya lo puse aquí
como número complejo igual a carlos puse
como número complejo muy bien vamos a
una operación un poco más interesante
que es la multiplicación entonces déjame
poner por aquí que queremos calcular el
z1 z1 por zeta 2 muy bien entonces
déjame sustituirse está 1 y z 2 acá
entonces nos quedaría a más b y v y x c
+ d y c + d y muy bien entonces queremos
hacer esta operación cómo le hacemos
pues aquí simplemente desarrollamos
podemos hacer todas las multiplicaciones
o el método foil también no me gusta
mucho el método foil porque es muy
algorítmico así que déjame hacer las
multiplicaciones pero justificando las
con
ley distributiva o sea voy a multiplicar
este por este y éste por este va
entonces nos queda
a por temas de i d i + + v y vi y x
c d y c d y muy bien eso fue distribuir
este número sobre esta suma pero ahora
podemos distribuir esta a sobre estos
dos suman dos y lo mismo con la be y
vamos a ver qué nos queda aquí quedaría
hace más a d y hace más y más b y c más
b de b/d y cuadrada
cuadra muy bien ahora observa podemos
simplificar esta multiplicación este y
cuadrada déjame tacharlo y ponerle menos
1 de una vez porque y al cuadrado es
menos 1 entonces podemos pensar que esta
suma en realidad de restar para que es
menos b de cómo le hacemos para
simplificar para que se vea como un como
un número complejo pues tenemos que
juntar las partes reales y las partes
imaginarias aquí voy a poner las partes
reales que serían hace hace y luego este
verde de acá tiene signo menos pero es
real si entonces no nos queda menos
verde
y esto de aquí sería la parte real de la
multiplicación y luego para la parte la
parte imaginaria tenemos que sumar a d y
con bc y entonces nos queda ade más b c
quizás ahorita hacerlo con variables y
con letras hace que sea muy abstracto
todo esto después con números concretos
es muy fácil pero la idea es muy
sencilla simplemente hay que acordarnos
que tenemos que distribuir juntamos
partes reales con partes reales y partes
imaginarias con partes imaginarias y
cada que tengamos un y al cuadrado lo
cambiamos por un menos uno es más o
menos sencillo vamos a la última
operación que es así está así mucho más
interesante y es la división de números
complejos imagínate que queremos hacer
z1 en 13 estados queremos dividir estos
dos números complejos que quiere decir
pues que queremos determinar a más b y
dividido en 13 más d
además de y quizás ahorita no me va a
dar tiempo de acabar porque ya me estoy
acercando a los 10 minutos pero la
propiedad que vamos a utilizar para
resolver esto o para hacer esta división
es la de diferencia de cuadrados esto es
de álgebra así de los primeros cursos
ese es un producto notable déjame
ponerlo por acá para acordarnos que
decía lo que dice es que si tenemos
números a y b y hacemos a más ve por a
menos b a menos b entonces eso nos queda
igual aa cuadrada menos re cuadrada a lo
mejor no no te sepas esta identidad o
bueno no te acuerdas cómo demostrar la
pero simplemente haces aquí el producto
desarrollas y te queda cuadrada menos b
cuadrada vale bueno el chiste es
utilizar esta pero para números
complejos por ejemplo qué sucede si aquí
ponemos más de iu y ponemos c m
a esa hora se ve es de iu y entonces
esto nos quedaría igual a c cuadrada
menos menos de y al cuadrado déjame
dejarle hasta aquí le voy a dejar aquí
porque se me acaba el tiempo pero
también para que pienses tantito que va
a resultar de esta operación nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo para continuar
definiendo la división de números
complejos